avec laurette philippot chargé de
campagne finance privée des amis de la
terre france bonsoir qu'il faut merci
d'être avec nous alors on parle de quoi
la duplicité des banques de cynisme
comment vous qu'elle y feriez ce
comportement
oui c'est ça il ya vraiment un des
quartiers qui se creuse de jour en jour
entre d'un côté un discours et des
engagements affichés de la part des
acteurs financiers et de l'autre côté la
réalité de leurs pratiques et dans le
cas de crédit agricole ce qui est
extrêmement inquiétant c'est que pour la
première fois on a pu vraiment mettre à
jour le fait qu'une banque qui s'est
engagé dans des politiques là elle même
développer et adopter
voilà que la banque ne respecte pas ses
propres engagements là et donc c'est ce
qui a été pointé du doigt la très
récemment et donc c'est extrêmement
problématique qui est non seulement un
green washing kick ass qui cache trop
souvent l'arrêté de réactivité mais
qu'en plus là on est dans un cas de
violation qui est clair alors selon
plusieurs ong dont vous faites partie
les banques françaises ont plutôt tout
de même fait des progrès mais elle
continue quand même de figurer parmi les
institutions financières les les plus
investis auprès d'entreprises polluantes
pour quelles raisons notamment cet
investissement dans le charbon
en fait on voit que le secteur des
énergies fossiles et finalement très
important pour les acteurs financiers
français et pour les banques en
particulier donc on parle aujourd'hui
d'entreprises comme glencore ou comme
marubeni dans le cas de crédit agricole
plus largement quand on parle d'énergie
fossile et banques françaises on parle
aussi de total de bp et de shell qui
sont des clients extrêmement important
et extrêmement finalement bénéfique pour
pour voilà le chiffre d'affaires des
banques et donc c'était vraiment cette
liens étroits cette addiction qui est
très forte qui bloque le changement au
sein des banques et donc en effet il ya
beaucoup plus de communication de leur
part sur le climat par contre les
banques françaises donc depuis 2016
c'est à dire au lendemain de la
signature de l'accord de paris elles ont
doublé leur financement aux énergies
fossiles donc en fait on est dans une
tendance qui n'est même pas à la
stagnation n'est vraiment à la hausse
très forte et donc nous conduit
aujourd'hui c'est que ce lien très fort
entre l'industrie fossile et les banques
ce ne sont pas les banques qui vont
pouvoir le cast est elle même c'est bien
trop autres c'est bien trop lucratif et
donc c'est nécessaire étant donné
l'urgence climatique justement que ce
soit l'état qui encadre les activités
des banques comme il doit le faire de
toutes les entreprises qui en fait bloc
l'atteinte de nos objectifs climatiques
quand même de gros sous parce qu'entre
janvier vous allez me dire si c'est
exact au pas entre janvier 2019 et
novembre 2021
1500 milliards de dollars de
financements ont été versés par des
institutions financières
ça paraît énorme
c'est ça ne sont elles pas règlementé et
ben non c'est somme elles sont pas
réglementées et c'est là tout le
problème donc là on parle pas seulement
des banques françaises on parle de de
toutes les actions financières au niveau
international et on parle de leurs
financements à plus de 1000 entreprises
qui sont actifs dans l'industrie du
charbon dont l'industrie du charbon
c'est à la fois l'extraction donc les
mines de charbon la production
d'électricité à partir de charbon donc
les centrales mais aussi tout ce qui
relève de voilà de de port de port de
charron et c est en fait parmi ces entre
ces entreprises une ceni l'entreprise il
y en a presque la moitié qui prévoit de
nouveaux projets dans le char tendant
charbon c'est à dire que non seulement
en train d'en sortir malgré les alertes
des scientifiques etc mais elles sont en
train d'aggraver activement un problème
est donc ce qui est extrêmement
inquiétant c'est que juste justement ces
1500 milliards sont en train d'alimenter
la croissance dans le secteur qu'on
s'est vraiment du passé et dont il faut
vraiment sortir dès aujourd'hui est ce
que dans le fond ça n'est pas un aveu
d'impuissance et ça montre tout
simplement la dépendance à ces énergies
polluantes et ben en fait hautement
dépendant de ces de ces énergies
polluantes et 1 mais on sait qu'il faut
qu'on agisse pour rendre cette
dépendance là et donc pour tous propose
ça c'est vraiment indispensable que ça
passe par la puissance la puissance
publique et par des politiques publiques
et donc ça veut dire à la fois que dans
chaque pays et y ait des engagements
assortis de charbon un accompagnement
qui soit fait par les états pour les
travailleurs également du secteur mais
c'est aussi indispensable que en france
on ne pense pas que tu as un train un
enjeu de de l'étranger un enjeu qui qui
se pose juste pour la chine et le japon
et d'autres pays comme ça c'est un enjeu
chez nous étant donné que l'argent que
aujourd'hui les citoyennes soigne
françaises et français maître dans les
banques françaises peuvent encore aller
à l'industrie du charbon dont on espère
que ça sera plus le cas de manière très
proche qui en fait c'est à l'état de
réglementer à la fois d'édicter des
règles à suivre par les banques à la
fois de contrôler leurs applications
camp comme dans le cas de crédit
agricole en fait les promesses ne sont
pas tenues merci beaucoup laurent
philippot d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france 5